good memories good memories good
memories
mammograms rotate these yummy today
because I got a little bit of a headache
you don't woman what I'm not doing [ __ ]
to take those braces off I don't know
why why would you never win why would
you put them in when you have to
entertain people hi because I've decided
what drill applaud can you tell that I
have them on no my shitty I'm fairy I'm
keeping the mic in front my mouth hey
don't make me feel so conscious man I
don't want to I don't wanna do this
don't I can't do the podcasters brace
Brian you told me I should start wearing
them or not while we're doing a show bag
okay tell that I'm wearing something
that that's ridiculous came from being
ridiculous brace Brian okay I can't work
with base bright huh did you wear them
last night everybody
watch yeah
did you like it recoil god did I wear
them last night no look man so that
white wearing them how was your brain
work me like you know let's put them on
I never wear them let me put it on why I
have Dean because I wore them all night
do you teeth hurt yeah I don't know you
talking about I hate them okay
I [ __ ] hate them see that's why you
need the metal ones like Frank Shamrock
so we can't do you have no choice
hey bro I'm on the Goldbergs I can't
show up as coach with braces it would be
funny but no you definitely can't they
can't write that into the script they
probably could but I'm not walking
around with [ __ ] braces on I'm Way
too cool for that [ __ ] yeah you are and
I'm not gonna be 50 with [ __ ] braces
adult braces are they make me sad but
you have them though I have Invisalign
sir those those are brace no sir they're
Invisalign in those braces I don't know
form of braces dude look I'm a little
sore from training and I have a bit of a
headache and I just don't I trained a
little concussed you know what it is
ma'am when you spar when you spar with
Daniel Cormier yeah D stuffy and Luke
Rockhold in succession when you don't
take a break did or we call that the
shark tank I was in shark tank will you
the sound you thought our shark and and
when you're taking one-minute breaks and
then you do when you really at the end
of the day when you do four or five
minute rounds d yeah alright cuz don't
think oh I'm sorry
six five minute rounds because I
I'm around Brianna Van Buren uh the bull
and yes and and then a Brazilian
gentleman with very very wide wide face
and wide cheekbones okay anyway the
point is that definitely knew that many
round straight but I hear you because
I've seen him it's a box and Bernie take
a nice long time ago okay so I get me a
three-minute round good no she want time
ago okay okay a long time ago okay now
I'm pissed I'm pissed at myself because
I let my as I was closing in on Daniel
he double like me so I didn't see that
coming either MMA's boring we doing some
little MMA spar yeah a little MMA
sparring Luca invited me to aka and I
get their thing I'm gonna hit mitts and
our boy name our courts there and unseen
name forever so good to see him and a
bunch of killer there full-time I think
he's training there just for yes to make
him he did some heavy sparring he was in
the cage it's Nate he disappeared and
went it's him he came back and his nose
was all it looked different I was like
you know he's a killer dude um did you
shut off all the boys after practice
well how's that were I was a little too
tired and my nose was it leading too
hard
hey you know so so Luke tosses me
headgear and I look in the gym and it's
all these pros who are getting ready
yeah and and I was like and Cormier goes
I got cat first what do you mean you got
Kalyn
so as I'm I'm moving around with DC and
when I say moving around of course don't
say spar never say you sparred with
anybody when you walk in there you're
moving around he's giggly giggly and I'm
and I'm I enjoyed I enjoyed hitting him
as hard as I could in the shoulders and
the chest and trying to hit his head as
he as my fish would bounce off that very
thick body he's the best yeah and then
he would pepper me a little bit pop up
and then hit me and then kick me in the
leg a little bit and then take me down
and then at one point took me down and
it was very interesting everywhere every
man should feel this because he goes
look look look look as he's driving his
shoulder into my lungs into my chest I
couldn't breathe and I almost started to
panic
I almost are just a panic like tap from
that and he got up and he
then after they played grab-ass with you
to camp do like real rounds after no
well yes / so so so so then Todd Duffee
gets ahold of me I don't know if you
know this but Todd's a little bit
athletic and a little bit big yeah yeah
and so Todd's joking around all fighting
on the youth team I don't know
we didn't talk about that he looks good
he looks does hit mid so athletic so
athletic and big freak and so nice and
tell me not to do he looks at he goes
hey Bry look around you see how stupid
this looks and let all these all these
belt holders really all these fellows he
goes he goes now do you know why you
don't want to dip to the dip down this
way you keep dipping your life because
I'm gonna kick you in the head and
that's what happens did he do that way
and you do a lot of that dip like yeah
yeah yeah and so we still haven't and
then he kind of beat me up a little bit
and then then Luke says to Brianna who's
a very good mm belt holder and a couple
divisions he goes punch his fit lights
out she's very small and she's getting
under my punches and pepper me fireman's
carry me taking me down I had to dress I
had to yeah I had to fight to just to
not him be embarrassed had to fight back
it's very embarrassing and then and then
Luke decides to start kicking me around
he's roundhouse to me in the [ __ ] gut
and by the way he's been at one point he
punched me in the face and I started
bleeding he goes woo little blood a
little but I'm like hey Bros is bleeding
yeah hey bro I can't have that man I
can't know that night - yeah I get my
face looked like both of the classes
could be there he wasn't man I was
looking shoes I would have called him
right out and taking him for some
tiramisu oh yeah further for those
suplex little black science I'm tara
misu
[Laughter]
anyway that that place it was my point
just Thompson there just he wasn't there
he's supposed to come to a show and he
never shoulda came no I don't know you
do his podcast um we had him set up for
chicken eat guy I love that guy yeah you
supposed to come out to LA yeah very
good guy yeah it was just cool man I
like I like being around it's for me
it's really exciting I'm such a fight
fan that's it - how many guys like me
get to actually joke around and kind of
you know move around with some like DC
or Luke Rock
yeah that's LAN tada yeah it is and and
I paid for it just shows in San Jose
great shows in San Jose
[ __ ] gracious I love San Jose I do
too man that that theater has got so
much history built in 1906 cool there
right then we had such a grab ass silly
time in backstage my last show Saturday
night when the Azim brothers did Stevie
go with him
he didn't go because they didn't have
they already had an emcee a feature they
had a feature Cory something and she
bailed last minute instead and I used
this amazing guy though this guy had
been doing stand-up for 14 years
it's got Chris really good so yeah
Stevie was missed didn't come this way
he's missing a while
Yeah right when I was at Cobbs I had a
guy you know I never do openers I do now
I did definitely and I need some you
need some yeah it's on now but Stevie
when I was in when I was in cobs I did
some gobbling he was hilarious
oh yeah hilarious oh you don't even
doings like seven years yeah well you
ever go to LA he's like I tried to know
you'll get features your features will
be have will have you by six seven eight
ten years or sure I mean that's what I
want yeah that's a big spot for a guy
who can get you know one of your crowds
gift that's what I want because yeah you
want a good show there's a lot of
people's what I say well a lot of people
look guys who aren't as funny as stupid
but if you look at the you know
obviously a guy who's killing like the
Rogen model he books killers follow
never be afraid of that [ __ ] mom you can
follow everybody doesn't matter
you're exactly you're so right about
that it makes the show better I've
always said that if my feature is
bombing if 20% of my audience is like he
should have been the headliner then I'm
doing yeah last night was fun I was at
The Improv one of red band shows oh yeah
do that
Aubrey came out all those kids came out
it's good nice yeah how'd it go it was
good yeah there's really good just a
different vibe in it to be an improv and
the coments very much so
but it's an important by hundred percent
had a play but not getting comfortable
the The Improv can be very difficult
sometimes it's really interesting so
yeah it's a different animal yeah
anata is oh like Lucy like calm East or
you can have some fun with the crowd
earlier
and by the way San Jose is not easy San
Jose because it's so spacious and you
got to tears
you you have this not even no no there
there are certain crowds there they're
also they're also intelligent they're
watching it's it's very diverse it's
it's interesting like when you go to
Denver it there best shows you'll ever
have the the effect on your face yeah
they're packed oh you're gonna you're
only ever wait I've never done the
Comedy Works downtown just first I'm in
some ways the greatest reaction
experiences they take your cell phone
and you get in there and it's such an
unbelievably tight room but it's so
beautiful and I don't know man something
about the acoustics and they go crazy no
and it's also part of it it's also a
homogenous more homogeneous sort of a
similar group of people so they all kind
of share a language there's something
about when you have a very diverse group
it different things that's San Francisco
like you had a strong Asian population
than you had why yes I've never seen any
more diverse I got Indian I got
Vietnamese I got Chinese I got Filipino
I got Mexican I got white I got I mean
it's literally the most diverse crowd
I've ever seen in my life which makes
fills me with pride I love it because
then my crowd looks like the United
Nations which depends where you go yeah
but it's nice because you're gonna say
when I was in Salt Lake is yes but I
feel like the podcast is listened to by
a lot of those people that's what I like
about it for sure you know I mean so it
was really cool man really really I told
her we Brian I have seen tornadoes that
came in trend by another house and but
mid next year put me on the road can't
kill just kill you kill you kill you
yeah that's already City because if you
don't want if you don't you want him you
want to do the road yeah thank you
by the way you watch how good you get
yeah there until the end what's still no
it's not Julia yeah cue the big man
doesn't like traveling it's gonna be
tough no I don't mind traveling I used
to be so you know in I was anti but I'm
flying around the state is fun you're
gonna [ __ ] love it no
stay tuned [ __ ] yeah you a lot of
international was a bit of a piece but
even I don't mind that anyone oh I know
you like watches and I held a hundred
and thirty-five thousand dollar watch we
were me and Yosef and Targ were hanging
out in San Francisco you know you and I
have not gone to the cool spots of San
Francisco what I mean we still town we
haven't gotten to like certain like
there were certain like the marina
certain areas like they're amazing which
I didn't know about maybe you'd have I
haven't I can't ever taken me to the
coolest parts of [ __ ] I was like what
how does this place exists I'm going to
other places it was unbelievable but
anyway long story short I go in there is
there's this watch guy he's making he's
fixing watches Italian guy handsome
tailored shirt 55 and looking I'm in
shape and he's got these he's fixing
these watches and so your servant are
looking at watches the way you do they
like watches I get a [ __ ] about watches
and because you'll like this what it
takes it out this this is the watch that
Paul Newman wore and you know that watch
that Rolex that Paul Newman wore in that
movie I figured you might know what the
Daytona I think so it's a hundred up Jim
it's a hundred and thirty-five thousand
dollar watch it was like he's this guy
brought in visited my dad yes vintage
because my dad left this to me and he
goes here to father left you a nice
present he thought some he thought it
was a piece of junk is can you fix it if
not and then he sold it to the guy he
didn't sell it he's just good I think
that's it that's it I think it's a
Daytona yeah yes that's it that's
exactly what it is so he goes like this
he goes his father he comes in because
my dad my dad left this for me and he
goes well that's a really nice present
he goes can you fix it he goes can I fix
it do you know what this is and he goes
no I guess well you 135 thousand dollar
watch and he was I want it apparently
the guy didn't have any money it was
really excited the only guy so I was
gonna sell it yeah how crazy is that
that's sweet I mean he said he I go it's
what he goes no you can get 135 for this
that's a great watch Daytona losers but
now I want to burn right now now I don't
oh well when I saw that not not that
exactly it's so cool-looking though you
can't go that's like you going from a
[ __ ] 1991 Civic EX DIA nobody but it
looks like a man's watch it to
understate it I can't afford that but I
want one
I like no dinkum but you can get a date
oh no that they look identical to hit in
Daytona
the Palmer one there you can get it they
make what I call the hidden what do you
mean the head is that one so exclusive
hard to get but you we can get your
Daytona way cheaper than that really
yeah like eight grand okay huh I might
have to start sporting a Daytona and
telling people it's vintage you need I
feel like you need a Daytona with a
leather band ooh I like a leather I have
to go Rolex shopping we do I like a look
at that thing that's the watch I [ __ ]
want I'm gonna up my game dude and I'll
buy some gucci boots
well what huh let's say it crazy
sorry hey um I watched Putin be
interviewed by Oliver Stone yesterday
now is it bad that after listening to
him in a band
I can't come for goddamnit do you have
zero backbone no he's so bad he's so
intelligent he was so intelligent and
all the things that I thought like I
could I have my argument for him but you
but you know your argument you know he's
uh doing it on Pearlie trying to be a
good guy like he's a bad person no no
but I I didn't see what I'm saying is
that his philosophical arguments and his
his point of view was very interesting
like I was bit was I had to really think
to follow his mind Chris he's a hard
truck get dad Tim how about this as I'm
getting out of my rental car as I'm
getting out of my [ __ ] rental car I
have this amazing cup of coffee from b2
coffee going place and you know it's one
of our boxes and it says Ethiopian a
there's such dorks but they make the
best co the [ __ ] guy stirs it with a
little brush you take forever
it takes forever it takes by the time my
coffee comes I'm [ __ ] older okay and
if you were like if you bring up any
workout equipment like what I mean
forget it yes you talking conspiracy
they're just they're just so there's so
low blood sugar but there's such
geniuses of coffee that's what they
weigh out yeah the [ __ ] so I got my god
I think that you don't want no no no you
don't want them on your side for a fight
but you want them to I would let any
outlet my girl hanging out there
all alone default in a thong and she'd
never have a Preston honey and have
dollar bills like that's that's the best
you should that's a good joke you should
develop that because that's the best
[ __ ] that's the best way to describe
it but um so but they make the best cup
of coffee and I'm savoring this [ __ ]
coffee and I'm like I've only had a
quarter of it and I'm gonna and as I
pull in cuz the airport from that
coffees up is what super eight minutes
away
no like this I'm is it now so I'm
sipping I'm savoring as I pull in I got
put I don't know what I might put the
coffee and I'm gonna pull into cuz he's
telling me to pull you know the return
of coffee dad say dropped it dropped it
I dropped it all over my like all over
the seat and all over my jeans up like
that my jig what might take it's all a
lot my dick and my [ __ ] and the seed
is completely [ __ ] so I go god damn
it and I'm gonna have to pay for the oh
I don't have to pay for the seat I got
coffee
I got a coffee ask in a coffee dick I
got another plane I'm so mad I go hey I
spill coffee all the drugs he got to her
I'm so mad the guy goes woo oh yeah goes
man this is bad because it seeps in I
don't know you gotta write a report oh
oh but I said either he's my article I
can either I put water on him you guys
think I should have but I I knew he's
gonna have to sit in it if he sat in it
I would've been a dick so I had to tell
him I'm just saying he could be got a
couple water and put it over my die
spilt water everywhere see a fellas it's
true until he sat in that tone and he'd
have [ __ ] coffee as a [ __ ] and I feel
bad about it so I had to admit it I
write a bill to see how much I wanted to
really sandwich topple into I was just
called meat and bread oh no that's not
no that's in Vancouver Vancouver yeah
San Jose and I I was so but I didn't
care about any of that I cared about my
coffee I was like mother [ __ ] there's
nothing better cup of coffee and they
make the best Christmas I've ever had
well thoughts the quick questions the
way the real what song the way you
really make no question chokolate in
mine dude they got chocolate a pound
chocolate they call a pound shockula the
way they read that they make it there
what they get him from you layer each
piece of dough with butter like each
it's tiny it's sick it's very hard to
make them that o it on Thursday I took
the whatever 6:00 a.m. flight Utah
that's fine for the cloud my early
flights off feed venture right when it
coffee tasting you did hold on I gotta
kind of stop okay before you go I want
to hear everything
but I have to say that the the Salt Lake
Roasting Company for me some of the best
espresso I've ever had in my [ __ ]
life it's nice so so so you're in the
right place so okay so now you you go
there I think I go to a black rifle
coffee okay you're thinking about
starting a coffee business yes so big
brown coffee go
so the big brown coffee and I I imagine
there's gonna be a big brown roast
big breath now the brown roast now hey
and and can we before you go in again
just quick now
big brown is awesome did I give you that
name all right no I what are you trying
to say no no I'm not let me ask them did
I give you did I did not name you big
brown we can go by you're the fan I
heard it was me okay what's your point
nothing that what are you naming the
coffee company there we'll see what
maybe the big brown Coffee Co no I'm
just saying I came up with a title
that's weird so I'm okay you see you own
someone what no I would never say that
I'm not saying I would never do that
yeah well my beak wet your beak I can't
get my I gotta walk around with a dry
beak get your beak tried it's just a
little dry I mean I go B I go through
the trouble of coming up with the label
and the name of your company
well I'm diggin Brown it's not like you
came up with well I felt like you let
the name soar some [ __ ] oh but I'm
putting Brown up but I definitely my mom
should get put up one team I put big and
brown together and I just feel like now
that came up with a name of the company
I gotta walk around with a dry beak you
beach drive cuz I could call or lonely
well I would never do that
hey man but if
but man's walking around with a dry beak
he's got to get some water right hello
chap that be cup I'm thirsty
well what makes it wet look no I'm not
putting a percent I wouldn't either I do
you know I'll make it off good idea you
know I can do for what what
easy now it's in your pants off you monk
your choice coffees drybrough coffees
dry bro no I be beat blood no blood from
Diggle Junction I don't you have a chat
be you know I did bring what you know
with my beat now I'm gonna beat it up
include the exclusive big brown coffee
mug every mine bro ceramic and drop
coffee still got me try I know what
you're looking for if I'm a desert let
me ask you if I'm gonna be buck if you
just crossed the desert and yeah it had
water in two days okay
okay ball your knees and I go here you
go and I shove a ceramic mug full of
coffee beans in there and I go have a
drink what happens to your beat stays
dry stays dry now you let see what
you're putting down yeah I'm gonna toss
them a third thing on this go ahead guy
right now I need you do right yeah
include a cold brew in that [ __ ] oh my
off on these I don't know what you're
looking for dude do I look like I make
chapstick I'm not it the big brown chap
look man cuz you keep talking about this
dry bean I'll take all those three
things I'm thirty percent uh would you
think if what look man I'll tell you all
right you know I don't have to tell you
act missing [ __ ] up you know I don't
want you doing that I don't get it you
know I'll do for its fair's fair you so
let's just talk about your little
royalty package yeah yeah so you get
your pound of coffee right yeah you
getting the big brown official mug okay
I'll toss a cold brew in there
okay call Bria and on what's month
that's what gets sent your house once in
Milan my wife I dig that the hold on
I do relax and we don't crazy don't know
bud stuff man I'm getting mad I'll pay
for your braces that prepaid bro nah not
done in your [ __ ] I'm talking about
the the high level like you pick your
colors and [ __ ] I don't matter one no
man I want rubber bands I'm not talking
about the work should I going on but
before you freak out about the words
retainer colored braces whatever we need
you right now
hey man hey it was fun though I went
there and tried out
they had like a straight coffee savant
and yeah he goes well the way we do this
call it cowboy coffee and he goes so
they you know they have the hot water
and they put the beans in it just has
all that then they float the top and you
got to break it your smell I smelled
like 12 different Wow
they let sit and he got taste all of
them was which ones you like and I like
like cuz you like a you like me like a
darker roast or at least where you can
you know what I mean cuz went over that
I drink so much coffee really he was so
nice and what did you sort of settle on
cuz it's hard to taste when your taste
buds you know you can get confused right
now
yeah but you know you know we're
figuring out logistics now but be like a
you know you're light lighter roast
which is still pretty dark ya know what
we like yeah and medium roast on there
dark roast you want to taste if quick
mom when I drink my coffee I want to
taste chocolate and caramel right yes I
want to taste chocolate and caramel I
don't want to taste lemon and it's
written of flowers and you lemon and I
think you know what's interesting just
learning the dynamics of the coffee
business is you know the pot I can't
[ __ ] with the pots I don't like the pods
then the espressos and I don't realize
and so I was talking to that guy who's a
straight coffee Silvana free of the
gentleman's name my boys matt is the one
who I'm doing the deal with but so I'm
talking to him and I go do the pots and
do anything Rios I know they don't he is
but they're our biggest seller it's also
Starbucks big
selenite what and also Nespresso yeah he
goes well but Nespresso has a patent on
theirs so he can't use any other pots
for an espresso only their pods match
well there's other possible [ __ ] the
machine out okay but everyone else's
pods work but the pots have the biggest
margins everything he's like it's not
you know the coffee in there doesn't
compare to actual roasting bean coffee
like it's just a how do you get how do
you get like the pods to be they well
how do you get them to be tough because
they have a long shelf life there's
nitric oxide in there they have to put
that in there oh you're the plastic you
got to guess the heat I just have to you
have to put essentially preservatives in
there and it changes the taste different
I just I've not I've never liked them
but he was like you got an offer because
so many people love them so offer those
the pods stuff like yeah but you know I
went into it thinking oh I'll take you
know put everything together I'm ideas
for thoughts designs the packaging all
that and then I set what the whole team
went through it like you looking about 3
to 4 months to knock out let me to do it
right everything sure yeah sure
anybody that she has to take yeah great
though man just learn about the coffee
and that's where they get their beans
and the Rose do they get their beans
like how does Grotta mala they get them
import from there but then they roast
them in Utah themselves so if you the
way it works let's say you I hook you up
with that royalty package and that once
a month they come when you order your
package or say it comes on the 15th of
every month you have a subscription yeah
which is what I want to out you I want
to offer you regular coffee but
subscription base too right so if you
order your coffee date once you order it
then they roast the beans they're not
like yeah yeah now when I love it it's
long we're gonna be drinking that coffee
we're gonna fire and kid will be fired
up it'll be it'll be fueled but I'm
always dropping this I get Starbucks you
know who better to have a coffee coming
in you but wait let me ask you is when I
when we get our coffee here yeah when
will it have been roasted uh what do you
mean so if you order it yeah it would
before they mailed it out so probably
two days ago that's amazing yeah yeah
they went through the whole machine like
you're honest and you don't know who's
crazy on spot it's crazy yeah it's cool
miss really cool man
yeah there's not
like that when you open it up and it
smells unbelievable the ins and out of
the caffeine those guys are for the
experts but this guy was so into coffee
a lot of it's the roasting right alot
some of it's the Arabica bean and then
then you got a roasted Arabica bean
what's a you know yeah which apparently
is a higher gross to higher altitude
yeah Wow yep it was cool though
Arabica we've come such a long way with
coffee I remember when Arabica came
along you know me i'm i watch a
documentary on coffee like a month ago
he did where if you were to put it on
when I was in tenth grade I would have
yelled at the teacher it was so boring
oh it was it was so boring but as a
grown-ass man I want to learn about cops
they just put it you know stick through
it I was interested it's just it's
boring I don't know what we'd do without
coffee one of the greatest inventions of
all time that's a drug somebody hit me
with this you know it's a poison right I
was like is it yeah and it's a central
nervous system irritant I was like good
shut the [ __ ] up
there's researchers he was warning and I
loved it and ya know it's healthy if you
do it when coffee gets in trouble when
you put all these [ __ ] creamers in
the sugar a lot but black coffee no
sugar free almond milk there should be
sugar in your nook anyways athletes
athletes they say it increases your
athletic performance there's so many
more positive research with coffee yeah
we posted negative when I drink coffee
my head is basically impossible to
connect with dude I had so much coffee
going through that where that the
factory that it was insane I was
bouncing off the walls I had to piss
every [ __ ] 30 SEC yeah yeah and you
put down some coffee you'll drink six
seven cups a day yeah easy will look at
me look at this [ __ ] right now and then
on my flight you make fun of me for this
i'ma take picture but it'd been awkward
i sat next to LeAnn Rimes you know it
comes Tina sure she had the same st.
Laurent boots I had on I hope you
brought that out sure did you know I
said uh killer boots man we had the same
boots she can have you heard her sing
have you heard her sing yeah Leroy he's
one of the the songbird over general I
mean I mean you're a singer chin what's
your take on her can we get let me hear
get her on first
cuz I won away by coyote ugly coyote
ugly oh no you don't know the song same
color but let's put that on Oh [ __ ]
she was good when she was a kid
hey wait just leave ride no [ __ ] sing
good god let's go to see a live
performance in see how good she is there
got this one 2017 go ahead and hit that
chin [ __ ] hater there are seven
people in the crowd right there her
husband was a typist - I had to happen
[Music]
you hate and chin I hate you hate and
bro pretty good [ __ ] American uh
pretty good
you really good broken it oh boy
I'm sorry she's not around by six or
seven kpop dancer doing moves
I'm trying to get her I'll do she signed
on to do Patsy Cline's life story on
Broadway shut up - coyote ugly however
what they say yeah I was from the movie
County you don't see the movie coyote
ugly tree ah [ __ ] bro myths and I loved
it when I was in high school well no
listen shut up hey you're wearing the
same [ __ ] boots what'd she say to you
she started laughing really yeah and her
husband I won't have that hat - anyways
her so coyote ugly then Romaric coyote
was like we're all hot the movie it's a
bar base where all these hot girls dance
on the barn like Oh party yeah hot
chicks everywhere and good time yeah
well Vegas was like that's a brilliant
idea someone was like let's open the
coyote ugly bar you have been Ecology
why well they're gone now because here's
the [ __ ] sausage fest every guy like
me was like oh yeah hot chicks and I bet
I've been there when it was the litter
much it should be a gay bar dicks it
should really gay bar DX ever they would
have they would have made Bank of is a
gay bar it was straight up cockpit he's
just trying to just call it coyotes dick
bump - you should speak Kiley's yep
coyotes gay bar exam would have [ __ ]
try to go to the bathroom and I just
getting dick bump bang bang bang they
change their us traded oh it's like you
went to a nude beach was just did uh-huh
damn shot hot chick threw me around
everywhere alone guys with their hand
country it was like this weird me it was
what a [ __ ] show it was like a weird mix
of dudes looking for hot chicks yeah
mixed with guys who were frustrating no
hot chicks were around and then there
was it was like having this country
theme so like you saw this cowboy who
was like kind of metrosexual
but no one really knew what they were
looking for they had the bros like me
showing up looking for hot chicks dance
on the bars right I love love a a bar
full of bros oh just a bar full of
brothers don't like peanuts peanuts on
the ground take the move maybe you get
recognized enough put their arm around
you in their sweaty armpit on your
shoulder and it seeps through ah you're
sharing sweat
Android hey coyote ugly that bar was the
word there god I'm pretty sure they're
gone their fight they're gone
I thought still in Las Vegas those that
he's there look it up Chester howdy bars
typing cuz I was give me a smash [ __ ] if
they would have done it right is scooter
still killing it I feel like they're
dying down somehow worse whatever whoa
so these are your chicken wings are nice
all right
they have nice chicken you don't comb it
for the goddamn flaming y'all I had
another for the tits I'm glad the
Hooters girls they were I feel that
[ __ ] come to my show in Tampa that was
fun we all went out afterward it's still
there though they're in New York New
York that place makes seven dollars a
night
Hey well you why would you go to Hooters
for the food how is he cold there Hey
look hotter day I'll go it for the
tittays and the chicken wings tail other
than that you don't [ __ ] with it all
right
you don't [ __ ] with it cuz then twin
peaks' came on went hold up we're gonna
take this model of hot chicks serve
legit food and beer and have you know
girls with big titties because unless we
go up to Hooters you go to Hooters I've
been there forever
used to be one across from high altitude
we used to train in Aurora
so we'd go there but that for whatever
reason there's like I don't have big
titties to work here anymore you know
they can't do that it was discrimination
I think they had a lawsuit against them
so awesome these flat-chested bras start
showing up you know what snow marble
wants me sometimes equal rind rights
suck because you know Boy Scouts are now
allowing Girl Scouts in a girl's it
let's reduce the Boy Scouts are now
water soaked there is now like so rules
are allowed like what what do we do if I
had a bar called big dicks right like
the big dicks and you could see dicks
and girls showed up and it was all small
dicks like what right [ __ ] right we want
dicks
I would I would have a bar we should
open a bar no clothes on Joe's will call
College Gonzo's and what we're known for
is our subs our sauce up I like our so
we have dope something to do like roast
beef and juice no shame no shirts
shredded and we have to have guys who
have the kind of sweatpants that are
made of cloth like that guy who came up
to me at there at the [ __ ] and he
goes what do you weigh more you got kids
are you waiting for that guy dude wait
for
now you gotta you gotta get a little
hardly and use your time on the base
yeah that's not sexy what I think we do
is the dudes no shirts it's gotta be
chisel obviously to work there you gotta
have a fat dick yeah we're crime it
number one we're after your dick yeah
hashtag no Harvey Weinstein where MC
your dick now what I want is a thong in
the front
it's called ganja's we can't steal the
Muffet baby [ __ ] okay we're not we don't
want to los now ya know what we're gonna
do is it's gonna have elephant ears on
the side and then your dick is a try now
can we not called trunks it's called
well I'm changed from gonzo because we
don't be soon I just call trucks trunks
not myself sir just says trunks are us
that's a really trumps are us now hold
on and now we have the best brew in the
land where you're gonna get hammered
we got wings we got wings now you know
what sounds like to me
what now if I'm pitching this yeah to a
bunch of successful due to I want to
invest sure they're gonna let you try
and go Sita so you talk about a game
pong yeah it's called trunk yeah yeah
trunks are us we go like this wow yeah
yeah well let me ask me ask me say is
that okay bar so it's a gay bar yeah so
you keep it real see you keep it super
keep super gay bar that's all I'm an
investor you in I mean you just pitch
this investor I'm the older investor I
look like Harvey I'm gonna go let me
just sure put everything that you thrown
out of a sure so yeah it's a restaurant
bar yeah okay it's all male waiter
waiter so you have no shirts on no
shirts on and then they're wearing a
thong in the front well but and visiting
an elephant yes because they have the
elephant ears yes okay and then and then
you wanna call it drunk yeah a trunk
trunk okay
and then you want to sell shirts that
say trunks are us right that's right
trunks are uh trunks are us and you
think you can get females in the door
hopefully we're gonna sell yeah well
[Music]
what no and you plan to sell just subs
yes yeah you Blimpie's shoutout to
Blimpie's they're gone no you're
Blimpie's essentially yes your subway
trunks trunks yeah
trunk you want a trunk which see I like
that yeah you want a trunk which you
want hold up
we only sell footlongs uh-huh well and
for the guy for some guys so don't feel
insecure give you a six inch err
nope no nope only footlongs
can we allow too much that's what she
said that's all we have okay and as weak
about something we will cut the footlong
in two and as we do it we go ouch
nope we never come what do you want you
want know there's you want an ouch no we
don't call that you wants to nip/tuck
you want snip tuck it
well nip tuck because we don't do that
here we don't even have knives to cut
these things yeah you to take the full
footlong
yeah and guess what yeah wheel off for
dark bread we only have the dark wheat
bread there's no white bread white coz
that's unrealistic but that's not true
there's some white guys who have big old
dog not like the black guys so we just
offer dark bread you know that I'm not
talking like wheat like that's super
specific there I know but listen just
hear me this was this the business pitch
again this you mean you pitch into these
successful white rich dudes so check it
out the bread I'm not talking about your
normal wheat bread where it's like kind
of like chinko I'm a heavy rye I'm
talking like a dark rye footlong bread
so when it's ready you immediately know
yeah lot of fiber but then it's a
footlong it's dark as these [ __ ] mics
but then also we got a nice honey glaze
over the top okay I like this but can we
just have the dark and an in debt that's
featured and it says not for the faint
of heart
so that's just for people who don't see
I don't want not only faint of heart I
want to scare people away because we
still want entice females come in we
want it to say so we won't say you know
what we could do yeah the half that the
six inches yeah white bread yep oh
that's good three inch wheat bread
because it's kind of mocha
I know what you're saying I'm not gonna
and then we got this hey don't hear me
out chin to have stagnant races the
three inch
very often do it I am NOT going to enter
into that well the three inches teriyaki
my same six Angie stereotype bro no no
he's on still you're not get rid of all
the Santos we'll just off let me just
lay this out you're the businessman let
me lay this out three inch it's like
that wheat teriyaki we only offered
teriyaki I'm not gonna no listen i
sketching eyes okay okay then six inches
it's all white bread it's it's it's
there it's white it's white bread just
standard Wonder Bread it's why it's fine
huh huh
you want the foot long you want the foot
long do good do stopping oh god get
these toppings you talking about the
dark ride for us that's so gross but
it's so hot I could do is you want good
you want you wanna do [ __ ] up for 69
cents what comes with it heavy
mayonnaise you know what the good news
package nuts
am i off on this no it's fine it comes
out of a giant dick the Mayo Sam what
happened too much what happened not
subtle enough bro nice obviously hinting
that I bred to be more subtle or dicks
trunk you don't need to say we got a
dick dispenser put out mayonnaise truck
the business plan is over all right
no no trung's trunks trunks are us yeah
we're not calling it dick now we're
gonna say get your beak wet get your
beak wet here trunks trunks all right
would you invest if if the entire
building was shaped like a vagina too
much what can we do to entice females
that come in though would you go into
that restaurant trunks MJ would you go
into trunks or it's embarrassing
I don't think girls want to be served
footlongs food speaker guy has only his
Dom covered because the thunder down
under' kills it Huber are gonna find
their way into the sandwich that's true
pubes you bro whoa whoa everyone is
shaved down yes these men are top-notch
Oh so before you show up we got to do a
little inspection oh but I have an
Armenian serve the goddamn food with
their hand
there's no sir everybody has to be all
they look like Rochelle Renaldo
Wow manicured yeah you shaved down okay
and we have a shave worried about do we
have a shave stay
no we don't Brian okay I'm just asking
no you been fluffing oh you'd be the
fluffer in the back hey boys lining up
got my straight razor hi boys it's
Monday some crunked trunks are us shave
butter all right
that's a bad thing we did a good job
thank you and if you want to invest in
trunks all's trying to do is blow out of
the water Kyle because that place
[ __ ] sucked
I can't believe they call it coyote ugly
in the movie what does that mean you
remember you guys got this you da
because go ahead go when you sleep with
someone and you regret it the next day
you'd rather chew off your arm like a
coyote then wake them up
I'll leave coyote oh that's lovely
that's good that dude is trunk ugly I've
never drunk ugly let's go look at that
you know her too girly fruity if the
man's dick is trunk ugly how many girls
have felt that way about me after they
Hey look at me put it down I know
especially in the morning when I hold a
lot of water in my face yeah yeah
there's not realize how old you are
right yeah yeah I'm like well you know
it's been a while now I'm just saying I
wonder my poor well you know when you
were a boy I wake up and my wife is like
what are you doing hey Jim what do you
think your issue with LeAnn Rimes is
[Music]
that drives me to the ball game warden
no I should have this [ __ ] pop yeah
why do you feel you have ill will
towards LeAnn I think she was amazing
when she was like really young and she
was able to sing that well but she got
older she's good
what what do you mean she was above like
she was greater than people her own age
when she was a little kid who was the
vocalist that kills you like who put you
in all Adele Brian McKnight Brian
McKnight is soul Brian McKnight Brian
McKnight pragma night you don't even
make music anymore ring I mean but he's
so amazing his ring back in 1998 he was
[ __ ] brilliant you know him from one
it's like a dream come true - I just
wanna be with you I hate
that's it
back at one is it's got damage first of
all so thirty five million views but
hold on this came out and went 2009
wouldn't you love those in that what do
you like be able to play piano like that
he plays piano amazingly too that's
another reason why it's awesome [ __ ]
song yes by the way my man - Shay - its
Brian McKnight I don't know you've never
heard of Brian McKnight he has a great
voice but that's a whispering voice but
I was like well he know he ramps it up
the dick your girl down dude 100% no he
I modeled his effortless after Trump's
2009 my man's in shape though I
appreciated it he's in shape and he can
play the piano - oh you should see him
play piano
so it's gay it's game over then it's
game over yes okay no thousand on TRL
dates it was game over yeah but what
about current you're done so here this
is him pretty current
I love them months ago ooh yes you gotta
love it look at this come on that's a
jazz that's a jazz jazz hands that's
those are jazz hands
what
Brenna's looking shoes I sure was they
look like greats camos there's a
Breitling watch oh that's what that is
it's a nice this guy's got it going on
just look at this it's super tight I
can't believe you ever heard of Brian
okay I think he's improvising this still
hasn't done
[Music]
the basis of need
what a [ __ ] skills Jesus against our
denim sure brother what a skill
it's also I would say six five six four
guys super tall yeah right
[Music]
dream come true
just be like the Sun yo do you oh do you
[ __ ] really do you in a joke do you
like it it's been out for ten [ __ ]
year do you enjoy this right stop it Jim
she kind of what kilo future I gotta get
to know Brian McKnight I'll tell you is
the best certainer in the world right
now vocal wise - and how you'll [ __ ]
what you sayin who know Mars number one
right oh yeah I think he's amazing he's
pretty badass actually part yeah he's
right now say he's the best in my number
one yeah he's dancing and his you know
[ __ ] his dance bring your lot vocals are
you gonna do for Sachi on the floor
lives
yeah all aboard oh my Rico oh she that
he's the best me see that his life
everyone says has seen him live or like
oh my he's the literally he's the best
in the world now he sees this one I hear
is the best her Sachi on the phone he's
ridiculous
you first
damn so tiny so tiny every slide x2
Taylor Swift I've won he's tiny people
say he's like five six but he's wasted
[Music]
you know there just be nobody calls
[Music]
[Music]
she's
Wow
[Music]
just naked baby letters cute
[Music]
Oh
that's just not easy
Oh oh yeah Chantal rut what's up but I
would sighs lonely guys in the bath me
too bro we got to start taking our dance
way more you really do
oh hey you know what's so funny about
YouTube there's 6,000 dislikes yeah
that's great there's 300,000 likes with
this 6,000 dislikes but there's 25
million views that is that is Stephen
numero uno him out next to Taylor's
first skills have you seen my carpool
karaoke it's a real picture to Wyatt
just human but hold on that's weird
though he's super tiny well he's a dwarf
no he's like five three they think I
think he's shorter Bubba I think he
might be shorter yeah that's a mystery
honey how truly tall he is
that's incredible he's tiny bit cool
yeah
Prince was like that tiny thing yeah
really the smallest person I've ever
seen okay I was I'm standing with it
next to him I was like you're the
tiniest human being I've ever seen he's
listed at five five would you not so you
know what that means
yeah yeah that's true Wow Tim the
weekends only five eight it's amazing
it's very strange
yeah he's so goddamn talented on carpool
karaoke him and uh yeah what's his name
Gordon Jesus James Gordon right it's
Gordon Gordon James Corden yeah Jim
Gordon James Corden yeah him and James
James Gordon singing it's ridiculous I
talk about hats so funny you have to pay
for carpool karaoke now your boy yeah
your boy Gordon's uh got in trouble with
is that one could events uh no but it
can be you sure just jump in before yeah
you got TRO for his weinstein jokes or
sing a thing he said I want to say he
said everyone looks so nice here tonight
in LA that Weinstein's gonna invite
everyone up to his hotel after this you
know something like that I mean you know
it's not terrible it's not a badge and
then he also said I think said everyone
here tonight looks so good Weinstein
would choose you over the pot tonight
the plant pot can I understand like that
it's not a bad joke no I mean why does
he have to apologize for that we can
we can all laugh I don't do I feel so
mad about that we're like Alma or Al
Michaels yeah the historic Sunday night
Monday night
commentator goes the Giants have had a
rougher week then yeah then Weinstein
and then he had to apologize it was like
[ __ ] oh we're doing this now give me a
break yeah I mean it's like we there's
always room for humor I'm sorry always
and if not as he wins and also the
Giants medal is so precious I assume
it'll be awful weak man the Jethro not
so it's to me it's funny you know it's
funny people show up tight these days
but also its hunting season man on dudes
let's be really he's got a yes it's
hunting season yeah and he's gonna
apologize you you know [ __ ] off like it
like you don't apologize for humor it's
a good joke it was actually a good joke
and and he's super super nothing is
sacred [ __ ] you do you want to hear what
he actually said yeah I think this might
be he's asked tonight like it's a person
tonight if you don't like that joke you
should probably leave now it has been
weird this week that I said watching
only ones deer on water
ask any of the women who watched him
take the bar it's weird watching Harvey
weisstein wanted to come tonight but
he'll settle for whatever potted plant
is closest that was it's a funny joke
those are funny jokes those are nut he's
not shedding light on the victims those
hilarion and by the way the victims are
can handle it and so can every other
woman and sorry and if you can't that's
not that that's not the comedians
problem that's awesome that's not your
own in so far off like I got like out
Michaels God he must got so much hate
cuz he had to go back on air and
apologize do him like I was that
thinking that contact is humorless the
last is the guys have had a worse week
than Harvey wine yeah the left wing has
been some articles a while oh why are
these [ __ ] people why are these why
are these tyrannical people on social
media controlling our humor and how we
express ourselves go [ __ ] yourself go
[ __ ] yourself
don't ever let these people bully you
you know yeah just a bunch of people
like you know yeah and and then Rose
McGowan who's been very very vocal here
YES on all this I mean she said I want
to smash the patriarchy fine are you
changing anybody's mind or you just are
you headhunting okay see what happened
see how it works out you know in the
audience vile roars and laughs show
exactly what kind of Hollywood you
really are I mean I know everyone a joke
don't tell me not not everyone is bad
not it not because they laughed it's
just it's a vision those are good jokes
those are funny hilarious yeah and it's
not me and yeah is it making light of
the situation yes sometimes it is and it
doesn't mean anything you know it's not
my response to be clear such salt is no
laughing matter
no I was not trying to make light of
Harvey at Philippi I was not trying to
make light of Harvey's excusable
behavior
yeah but why does he even have to say
that I would never have done that I
would say go [ __ ] yourself and take a
joke but there's so much pressure you
know that you can you can lose gigs and
stuff no you know Twitter's trying to
they're trying to come up with a way so
is the Instagram that you know cuz
there's a bullying of Rose McGowan and
all these people that they're saying if
it becomes a intoxicating like negative
atmosphere Twitter's gonna be [ __ ]
try agree
and I don't know what ideas have been
put out there I think the only way
people shroud to comment on Instagram or
Twitter should be people that are your
friends
you can't you set that that way or also
don't you really yeah you can set it
that way and also I don't know man I
just think we have to remind ourselves
that that that nobody has to be
protected from opinions and ideas
because because it's like point B you
miss them I get all that you missed the
point
bullying non-stop bullying if people
date to take over the social media
so like like the lead from ghostbusters
the the comedian the black later yeah
you know she's my friend you have to get
[ __ ] they get off Twitter it was so bad
yeah those aren't thoughtful ideas and
creep fear and their shitty potato or
yeah so that's what they need to figure
out I don't know how you figure that out
I think that if you're gonna step into
the space of social media you're gonna
deal with that in one way or another
you're gonna be Bruno Mars yearning at
6,000 dislikes you would deal with hate
I deal with hate we all deal with it
some people way more than others you
know the ugly comes out and I think if
you put yourself out there I'm not so
sure how we ever protect ourselves from
that and I I think maybe the answer is
to ignore it to take power like world a
one thing that's good is humor humor
does help a lot a lot of times in
defusing a lot of you know not doing has
humor though that's not gonna be overall
I just think that James Corbin I could
we're when we censor people and we
censor humor we're in trouble we're in
big trouble I think yeah I don't think
James Corden should even address them I
should just keep on keep on I think he's
super talented and hilarious all right I
thought his jokes are awesome yeah most
of the country doesn't agree with these
people most of the country doesn't agree
with this tyrannical sort of and
left-wing and right-wing fringe sort of
group that are controlling the debate
you know people who are they're very
angry and coming out and and you know is
that the hardest part was to open in the
world what's going on just loud and try
to get quiet I went to a lot of trouble
to get the purple they did
chin in any news on your dating or
anything no nothing nothing have you
heard from the girl you got a lot of
[ __ ] playing hard to get out of saw I'm
not speaking of hate
you a lot of hate I don't care what they
say yeah but now we've been just
messaging on text that's it haven't seen
each other would you do this weekends
are there what did I do this weekend not
going date no I bought a camera that's
all I did pretty much well cut what do
you mean a camera GoPro have you been
recognized for this show walking down
the street yet I've been recognized what
we go do shows together sometimes if you
caught me on the street wait why would
you would you buy the camera for just
for fun to record myself more shy cooler
I mean what do you do it are you jumping
out of a wrestle singing I am fishing
yeah the POV cam while you're holding
the look in your trunk
working your um and then you're gonna
upload it we're on it scrim yeah most
likely Instagram it's exciting I know
you know we have a gentleman coming
today I didn't tell you this earlier
just as you got to keep moving you know
I'm saying the gentleman coming today to
help us we bout to go live thank you
about to go live come in at a live
stream this [ __ ] don't say we're trying
to figure out today is that a good call
tell you uh MJ would you do this weekend
I'm a Sikh rumblin right now you've been
sick all weekend no you didn't have to
come in I was like yeah you get the flu
I'll be afraid I just started reading or
listening to the audiobook sapiens oh
the good Phoenix I'm like zoning out on
the car ride though it takes me time
yeah it's a great bonus I recommend it
you've been super sick you know like
since Saturday night I sure didn't have
to come in I don't wanna like bail the
team I went to Hornets a horror horror
so where's this was it photos it's
always too crowded so you don't get to
go on everything you have to go early
used to go like before like like before
like 7:00 they have early arrival
because the lines for the mazes were
about 100 minutes so like yeah I mean
did you get the gun I went on everything
but the shining and one I was going it I
went on it they had for like the tram
ride or the tram ride was Chucky I went
through a few like haunted houses it was
a lot of what like waiting honestly do
that it was just different me a ticket
so I did that that's cool though huh
sounds fun mmm kids gonna start a
picture of you and Tiger where he's
squeezing the nose the petting zoo with
the petting zoo yeah he loved it
these there's these two uh sheep just
[ __ ] with dis fighting like race
ramming each other I'm talking like
straight up like Brawley oh my god damn
it you see so I'd like take him like
separate on all the kids like why each
other Ned there's a black sheep that's
diagnosis there's this black gene that
would not let the white sheep eat
anything and I was like well this is
[ __ ] up so then I gave the white sheep
some grains or the [ __ ] they give us the
black sheep did not like that started
beating the [ __ ] of the poor was a young
RAM dude
no he was just they're both same size
would not leave them alone horns they
both had horns coming Rams I did I
separate them yeah
bad move it pissed the black one off
even more start beating the [ __ ] up in
front of the kids
kids started crying yeah my kid tried
feeding them his hand got smashed so in
college high school actually there was
my friend at a farm and we were all it
was like a big high school go out outing
and I'm trying to impress the girls and
there was a ram not a not a full-grown
Ram because you get [ __ ] up but this
Ram was like a young RAM and if you got
near his girls he would Ram you yeah and
we run over and start petting the girl
he'd come over and [ __ ] this pad just
petting zoo it's at the growth so there
was like terrible story be but there was
a terrible story okay good
so here am you today ran name you're
lying cuz you trying to save the story
and save us all not I'm I would never
try to save story I thought so you ain't
College and then you were be with these
people and her there was a ram and you
pet the RAM and be close to Rascals
right now it's you oh hey can you wait
anymore so the RAM was like oh man hey
me I was like laughing and stuff like
that they killed him he ran me into
another pen and a full-grown Tiger
Mountain Ram oh wow yeah what the curled
Hornet says and you guys father down
nope it hit it came at me and hit me and
threw me in the air and and I was in the
hospital for two years concussion here
okay yeah but this is weird because that
dispenser did there's aligned forever al
I'm just there's a line forever and
think about it animals don't eat all day
what's your truck they give everyone
food I'm like wool guys I beat all day
yeah so I tell they I go it's a little
weird just everyone feeds him like my
head I saw I've been here since 11:00
for I see you feeding him up
don't didn't not healthy she goes what
are you the the pet police she said yeah
right I started laughing it not the pet
but you're right I think it's like it's
like you know but she goes oh is it
you're an airway I guess cuz like you
know what
hey sheep Nazi yeah [ __ ] you how about
that yeah
and then there was a llama and I just I
grabbed his neck you've seen a llama
with the long night yeah I could I mean
I feel like you just wring his little
neck oh no I I could fit both my hands
around his neck was that skinny yeah
yeah I could what it was like like think
about it we had an ostrich egg an
ostrich they're so strong this one will
kick you in the stomach
no I'm talking about this [ __ ] this
little llama man I feel like I you just
wring his neck like you're Indian
rug burn and kill him I thought about it
I've never do it and actually got a
picture me on my hands on his neck I
thought you know what we're not posting
that because that looks wrong yeah but
hundreds of kids feeding these animals
all goddamn day
it was hot as [ __ ] out I like this can't
be good for these and yeah that's a lot
of food there's tooth there's two dot
there's two donkeys I'll give them the
food and then I just your felt the
donkey's nose sure have written a donkey
they're glue written the burro I love
their noses and pig nose is overrated
man yeah they're very crunchy very dry
before you go we're gonna wetting a beak
yeah the pig nose is not something it's
it's it's a routing it's a routing tool
you know it number one you know number
one knows for me hold on that's be juicy
hold on I'll see dogs noses usually
number horses for sure horses just like
it's very hard to know it's nice a young
calf a young calf knows the older calves
the Gila drum part I still like them
though I still like young calves fat
cows knows it's soft why are they so wet
all the time
I don't know and they're cute is [ __ ]
a young calf snows try it out people
they are right I've never felt the
zebras or imagined pretty nice ah yeah
bite you know hard and not let go zebra
will bite and not like a zebra yeah what
do you think has the softest nose in the
world now I'm now I'm obsessing wait
about a nose yeah funny bunnies
[ __ ] call the bunny is it's like a
meth addict their noses do not stop
they're just going
cosmic on see sniffing what the [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] you smell em all the time
no non-stop non-stop non-stop stive aunt
nobody that does this like she has like
a tick
well wrap it to do that 24/7 my aunt
numbers like a giant rabbit chilliness
she'll think Jake a giant rabbit with a
tick
why do rabbits smell constantly I don't
know I'll tell you what's underrated -
for nose and hear me out here I know
they carry a lot of diseases they've
killed a lot of people but there'd rats
rats rat rat actually we're kind of
adorable a nice clean rat is cute a
clean rats cute now you get that San
Francisco or LA downtown round not the
tunnel rat don't live with it
Bruin rat nice [ __ ] fresh cows you
need any any feet they have nice feet up
- I'm not a star objectively cute I'm
not a food guy I like a rat foot a nice
clean pink rabbit they're soft they're
nice they're are kind of adorable you
have to admit yeah look at the rat wait
what about a chinchillas nose ocean
shows are cute yeah hey tied up in
chinchilla tied spinach and softest nose
in the world humans aren't [ __ ] up
there but look at chinchillas all the
way I have to think what do you think
well that's what I'm trying to think put
about soft let me just see I'm sure
there's a list cuz there's a whole
fetish with this thing I have people
here horse that's a horse Shetland Oh
well a lot of horses are popping up but
there's no list
there's no [ __ ] horses very soft
knows who's soft it's like you know what
it is it's like a peach that went bad it
really is and when you feed a horse a
carrot oh look at the proboscis monkey
what we're that's a proboscis monkey why
don't I [ __ ] think of that well no
they have a dick for know the proboscis
monkey but it's soft like a dick yeah
that might be number one yes dick sir
softest well they're very soft
dicks are stood he looks like there's no
proboscis the original dick knows here's
a yeah that's it that's a rebus 'kiss oh
I didn't like that knows his ridiculous
Oh
terrible-looking hey hold on first of
all oh hello seals elephant see a 100%
dude 100% that thing looks pretty soft
what looks like it has calluses on it
ooh a hippo nose any bad no it's not but
it'll kill you have you seen how fast a
hippo swims yes we brought that video
but never before god damn well elephant
trumpets are shot they're hard um
sheeps nose look at the cows nose and
tell you Coco I think it's really a
house number one for today it's gotta be
horse or so I got a giraffe I didn't
think about a giraffe a lot of those
wild animals have hard they're much
harder than half you can't be perfect
than the water is it chinchilla you
don't know you don't even understand how
close softer chinchilla fur is no I do
understand ho goo cheese not doing for
any more breaking news gather that's
pretty cool um however the chills nose
it's awful and you're obviously not a
nose person horse uh and I'm telling you
a nice young calf who hasn't been around
the world is really nice yeah you know
what you've seen a reindeers nose a
straight-up deer a juicy black there
goes in the face so I know about them
but they're hard but like it's almost
like a gusher yeah
chopped one of their heads off and I've
felt your head
well it's delicious it looks awful [ __ ]
oh well I don't know about a straight
deer so that's a reindeer as a reindeer
just type in here no that's what the
[ __ ] oh that nice black sauce that makes
me sneeze all this nose notes you're
some current events that's a cute little
deer I don't like killing deers by the
way I love the way they taste but I
don't like actually I've ever had deer
oh I have some in my [ __ ] we go on
white truffle tonight though yeah yeah
baby oh did I on you you're gonna love
it yeah dinner army it's pure you know
okay white truffle white truffle season
white people send me a bunch of dm's
about white truffle the
a whole like tribe of white truffle
hunters I guess yeah there wants to be
part of it
I'll tell it's my truffles how would i I
love it
nepeta Nelly Dorota Larry Flynt offers
ten million dollars for information
leading to Trump's impeachment he took
out an ad on Washington Post yeah entire
page you think anyone's gonna get
anything nope you don't think so
I don't think I don't even think the
rush of investigation is gonna turn
anything certainly nothing in Peter Bowl
you know there's a Jimmy he'd do this
before listen he do this he did like a 1
million dollar reward for something but
I'm not sure if he did this before
though for uh he this isn't the first
time he's done something like this he
did it before it actually kind of [ __ ]
on over - well like Trump had as some
very similar ties to Weinstein that's
for sure yeah I don't know yeah but he's
done this before yeah nothing probably
gonna come because when you become
president you don't think the Clintons
could have found stuff while they're
trying to go out he's got Trump's got
lots of lawsuits for groping tons so so
um I think as many other why president
while in office is protected from civil
suit oh and I believe from so so he can
be sued afterwards after he comes out of
office 2007 he offered 1 million for
call evidence for anyone who had an
illicit sexual encounter with a member
of Congress he was happy there was not a
sensor Oh My Damn
yeah he was looking for hypocrisy yeah
what does she get Jen all right that
Nellie accuser yes she now says that she
doesn't want to go through with it
she doesn't to testify because she's
she's afraid the system's gonna fail her
which is really really yes she did she
receive a payment as well
no no payment and Nellie wants to
actually go after her
[ __ ] yeah he does defamation of
character is really screwed him over I
think that's a form of you're trying to
murder somebody when you fall sick you
somebody if that's what happened was she
she hadn't called 9-1-1 because
she believes the system's gonna fail so
she's just like a [ __ ] to the system of
yes terrible he has to do that if
anybody can do that when you get accused
of something like that it's [ __ ] the
side we live in especially right now
with 19 stuff and yeah the whole hashtag
you're guilty I'm all about the the
hashtag me too and people with voices
getting they feel you know free talking
about it and they feel in a safe place
where they can talk about that's all
great but it's also like now as a male
in society man you better watch your P's
and Q's a little bit Ahmad mentality to
like an anything sometimes hold my hand
hold my hand because you'll get just
this wave of this diss immediate and
huge backlash that kind of creates a
wave it's like the pendulum in this
country always swings with one extreme
or the other and we lose common sense
assess critically that's so important so
important um yeah what else you got
look at that Jason Aldean resumes his
tour which is gonna be good for him back
in Vegas didn't like Tom don't come back
to Vegas you ain't wanted here boy who
said that Dana White you know what he
was mad at him why would it even matter
to him
he invited him over for UFC 216 to sing
the national anthem and he said he
doesn't know if he wants to sing live
again especially in Vegas I get it I
mean sweet but that guy a minute hey bud
I'm a night on Saturday night was like I
know if I'm singing like I get live
again he was on Senate live singing life
dedication Pompey yeah I saw him I saw
it you know but I thought like you know
cuz I've been in that studio Saturn I
live that's in a closed area right in a
very small area there's maybe how many
or other 50 people yeah I mean if that
may be a little more than that the moon
yeah whereas with this this is in UFC
and a huge thing across the street from
the shoe to have to understand that he's
got it he needs a minute needs in that
good but also certain that live you know
you know maybe watch each let's say he's
performed at at the UFC you know any
pay-per-view buys one that you see about
120,000 under 20,000 really more people
listen and watch this podcast I could
put a YouTube video
of me mulling those shoes and get you
know it's like but no one's paying for
it now that's I I don't think that's all
the UFC's fought I think that's a
combination of Tony Ferguson Kevin Lee
not the biggest draws Mighty Mouse not a
draw no you know around Vegas time of
the shooting no one would really be part
of that
he's just so sober mood so a lot of
things but the the previous one that
that was even lower about 114 thousand
bytes
I heard Luke Thomas say I'm he did the
research I want that one
take from it what he did and might be
wrong so credit you guys are correct me
but he said that it's the lowest
back-to-back pay-per-use they've ever
had since UFC like 42 when I was like
you know kiemce over someone and ken
Shamrock or someone else right wow it's
rough what else yet Jim alright people
have been sending me this OJ Simpson
just out and about again oh [ __ ] he's
back so he's in Vegas mingling with
women it's not even a big story but oh
he's out three different women yeah yeah
just hanging out I'm you know what so
you just went straight to Vegas yeah
where they're trying to get them banned
from Florida
the prosecutors like you know you can't
we don't want you in Florida needs like
my kids live I'm so hanging on the kids
out you don't want you here okay Tim
Kardashian says Caitlyn Jenner is not a
good person
she's crazy keep scrolling down Jim Pao
is anything else on OJ no I just him out
and about cuz he just got out and he's
already uh hanging out drinking chilling
with women oh yeah so this movie came
out happy deathday and it's already
beating out Blade Runner 22 v 49 to play
trial they're supposed to be amazing
they say happy deathday does look good
this came out of nowhere
movies always kill it though we just
wanna watch the trailer yeah
it looks good I definitely want to see
it oh I saw this yeah
every day she wakes the same thing gets
killed you're up Vienna
yeah I folded your pants for you little
[ __ ] maybe you should switch to water
next time super helpful
don't be late to a party tonight okay
buddy
[Music]
damn and she has to kill him before he
kills her I solved the case I love me a
nice scary movie Oh chin Dane eye dog
well scary movie date night you know
when you watch a scary movie it really
same endorphins as sex you guys talked
about that before
trying to drop some knowledge on I'm
trying to get the date what but it's
kind of hard one dude how scary with
this being assuming that I believe any
of this is even possible the way I see
you have unlimited amount of lives
unlimited opportunities to solve their
own murder we all know this is the same
movie that Tom Cruise did end of days we
kept dying to they figured it out okay
who's the actress whoever's killing him
well that's that's that I wonder who the
actress is Jessica Roth hmm name is
Jessica Joffe so relatively brand-new
right oh yeah oh yeah I'll definitely
see that movie that I love me some
horror movies oh you know what I would I
watched Sleepy Hollow giant dad that's a
good one
old school mm-hmm and now watch monster
Charlize Theron your girl patty right
then I went down a weird rabbit hole and
started watching actual footage of the
serial killer the woman said yeah god I
mean one us yeah that person well I yeah
what were you saying well the reason
that we watched I was with patty we
watched all the stuff about Eileen
warned us and this is forever ago
obviously and she said she was turned
into a monster and she said that was the
the theme of this of the movie she goes
I'm gonna write him I'm gonna write a
story about her life how she was how
just her life she loved yes and so
correct Patty's like her back radix
point of view yeah her sympathetic point
of view on this girl
society turned into more
this monsters she was such a good job
she was kicked out of the house she was
raped by her grandfather's best friend
who then impregnated her and she had to
have an abortion then they kicked her
out of the house she was homeless
forever
to make money she had to turn to
prostitution she was raped
battered it's constantly constantly and
then she's 13 years old when she was you
know when she had enough of that and
then started to kill the John's and then
but then it got a little weird because
all her anger she was like I'm just
gonna kill these guys now she went crazy
she went a little bit crazy yep Charlize
Theron plates I mean it to me as an
actor 80 as an actor III believe it's a
it's probably the best performance I've
ever seen ever like I think it's I think
it's up there with the top three
performance or two which way if you if
you watch the movie it's old-school
movie so I'm sure that people see them
but you don't realize how good Charlize
Theron is until you go back and you
watch the actual footage of what's the
soreness Eileen Moore's you watch oh my
god teeth red spot and Patty's such a
freak Patty's like but they wanted to
shoot it in Canada and Patty goes
absolutely not thinking what do you mean
this is a new director patty was like
uncompromising cos we have to shoot it
down in Florida they're like why and
this is why patty who is she is because
the lighting is different there the
light is different in that tropical part
of the world it's it will ruin the movie
if it's up there and I was like why
really well she's right she's that
detail-oriented and she understood
that's right she understood dramatically
why that light why it has to be shot in
southern Florida that's where it took
Charlize Theron's put on thirty pounds
to play the character she talked about
she went into deep depression after
she's hard for her to lose the weight
right after it's crazy man but do you
watch all this stuff on the actual
circular like holy [ __ ] but that see
recovery
she made the eye leaner she made a good
point she goes you know sirico is
usually they get off on the killing
stuff I got she was I never thought now
she was they call me a serial killer
because I committed multiple you know
killings yeah she's but I'm technically
not as I'm torturing yes she's like I
showered torture me she goes then I so
didn't get pleasure for it like yeah I
didn't do it for a high and right high
from night that's right yeah that could
started to destroy her she started to
spin out of control yes you made the
movie
to make sense he's such an amazing movie
it was so good I've seen it you know
probably three or four times I watch it
over the weekend I never forgot that and
I remember when Patti called me and said
I mean Shirley's throne signed on and
then Patti was worried because they were
like she could kick you off the movie
get some soap out yeah and because Patti
was fresh out of AFI American Film
Institute and it was like she was just
trying to make it and I you know at the
time we were you know dating yeah and
and and she I remember I was in the
editing room and I saw the scene where
Eileen warned us asks christina ricci
for help and and I was I was watching
with my mother and my and Patti were
editing it they were sitting it and they
were watching it and I started to
[ __ ] cry because I realized that
Patti had done something great and I'm
you know I'm not very comfortable with
emotion um I've never cry started to cry
because it was I was it was glorious
like I was like oh my god my friend did
something so dia I couldn't like I
looked at her differently like I looked
at Patti Jim Shyam pregnant
I did not I did not we weren't even I
think we were probably on a tail on the
vote the relationship there but but I
looked at her and I remember looking at
her for the first time like I didn't
realize she had that in her you ever see
that with somebody oh I didn't know you
had greatness like so good yeah it's
really cool when I sketch and I was his
scary movie I don't know right all right
how about this a kid in the same
neighborhood ended up breaking into his
neighbor's house good looking kid to the
Jonas Brother for god sakes
I know brick breaking into her house was
she was sleeping he had a mask on held
her at knife point and raped her after
the rape he kind of just kept talking
her and talking her and then he said
like I didn't want to do it you left her
you had no deadlock on your door so I
had to do it and he said he would make
it up make up for by doing yard work or
anything I needed repairs around the
house yeah he's just completely out
there yeah he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah crazy are you crazy
so he's in jail now just so 100% yeah he
needs some help yeah this last one
this is a little weird so a guy's
charged with stealing 1.2 million
dollars worth of fajitas the [ __ ] do you
still at me fajitas we were in love for
he does bother you miss link fajita you
makes a nice feed I'm bidding forever
chiles
yeah there used to I mean it's [ __ ] food
what do you get for heat of this these
days ah God I like what he doesn't know
what's annoying about fajitas
we are fajita it's like cornball service
of the club makes a big scene it does
make a big steam and never breathe that
same in by accident no but like everyone
knows you know it's like bottle service
in the club your delight yeah you the
[ __ ] sizzling fajitas yeah everyone
knows it's coming your table about your
birthday when I was a kid happy burn
with a huge cake that's different than
me fajitas it's a Monday afternoon
hey kid like Altima heaters I don't want
the goddamn attention though you know
that's very condos fajitas were annoying
as [ __ ] but a cover on joint put him on
a sizzling platter yeah I don't need I
don't need [ __ ] Benihana at Chili's
you know I'm saying ya stream no make
sense anyways where'd this guy see all
these fajitas from he worked at a
juvenile justice center and he somehow
for years allowed the truck that
delivered the fajitas to get to him
first so he would take the fajitas and
resell them and the couple or the job
the Juvenile Justice Center would
continue to pay for it but they didn't
realize they were doing that so he did
this for nine years yeah a side hustle
some fajitas fajitas the [ __ ] was he
selling these fajitas though it doesn't
say where he sold them he's just
black-market fajitas I'm sure those
aren't that hard to get and maybe just
sell it like the grocery store or
something yeah he would Jack him and
then sell him so 800 pounds of feet is
here in this particular occasion he
wasn't there he was sick I like this guy
and they found how we're gonna get a
nice fajita Brian I'm trying to think is
there's a place called El Cholo um on
the chain
nope and they they make it they'll make
you a sizzling feed now the soul you
know soul play this is the best
and I've ever been to besides I imagine
but do they have fajitas automatic he
does these days you so sizzling fajitas
maybe was that restaurant called eternal
soul and Playa Vista is amazing the best
[ __ ] roof they got they got a taco
Corps the van Baro
the van buren oh god is that a vampire
taco
is it full of bull oh my favorite
restaurants California my mouth is
watering
I've been eating today I got a pee go
for your piss hot yeah let's do it
bum bum bum bum bum so um this is
fascinating do you understand what the
the scientific method and the Scientific
Revolution was what historians call the
birth of ignorance which means that
before science there were no secrets to
the universe the secrets were all in
religious texts they were all in the
mythology that was given to you so even
even if religious texts didn't you know
talk about certain things like I don't
know cuddlefish and how they lay eggs
that wasn't deemed important to God but
all the important things were fixed and
they were sealed in a book and then
along came the Scientific Revolution and
here's why this is so important to
understand what we benefit from here's
the scientific method one is ignorant
that we do not know and and in fact as
you begin to study something we also
realize that when you arrive at a
conclusion based on the scientific
method also keep in mind that you may
find out that you're wrong
upon further evidence okay so as we
develop more evidence you might find out
that you're you what you used to think
was true is false right then the next is
how do you prove it mathematical models
observation mathematical models you tie
those together and you create a theory
now you got a theory theory
any theory of relativity whatever it is
a Tesla what's the third one conclusion
[Laughter]
like me conclusion look very good but
sort of no it's not enough to just have
here admit that you you don't know then
you prove it with mathematical you come
up with a theory you prove it
[ __ ] application need some evidence
you got you applicant the evidence of
you apply it to new technologies you
actually apply it to a technology so the
phone that you use proves that it works
so we we use it we apply it to tools
that we use all the time and when you
understand that that that is literally
so important and it's such a massive
development in human cognition because
before it was always but what's
fascinating about all that is this okay
so that's the scientific method we know
that science works
we know that the science in the food I
mean in the you eat in the phone in in
the antibiotics used in anesthesia we
know how it works okay so we can use it
it's a technology however you can't live
on just that science alone
you do need mythology right you still
need the idea that some things are not
provable but they are what we stay alive
for you can't measure why music we talk
about faith talking about faith don't
have faith and that's why we brought you
guys and that's a cognitive dissonance
yes we have Jesus Jesus is that you drop
knowledge we need Jesus we at the end of
the day my dominologist
we need Jesus in your life there it is
that's right
huge development though in human
cognition we a science starts with the
basis that we don't know oh and here's
the main the main dropping knowledge
other ones no this is the conclusion
maybe leave your life a little bit like
that it's really easy to think that you
have the orthodoxy that you think you
have the truth but maybe be more
scientific in your methodology and admit
that you might think you know but keep
open the possibility that new evidence
may come to light that might change your
address and lab bewildered yes be
willing to change your mind admit that
maybe you're maybe be a little more
uncertain than you are sir
sometimes that's all thank you brother
doesn't mean you can't be faithful
doesn't mean it can't be religious
that's all just allow for that that
cognitive disheartened dissonance right
open your her scientific method I got a
have I got you I got you
were you gonna be be glad you asked
buddy I'll be in Calgary Canada this
Thursday Thursday Friday Saturday you
can see me at yoga insight companion
first time heroes in studio damn it I'm
missing it Rana gave me missed it hurts
me that sucked
we don't fight me and Sarah cowboy
Cowboys fight oh it's real fighting I'm
sorry forget monster yeah monster
monster anyways go see Bryan Calgary
though come see me in Calgary I'm
excited love Calgary lots of fun a lot
cast we just announced dates I'm back on
the road in November Colusa casino
Charlotte Nashville Charlotte Columbus
Ohio funny bone great funny bone those
are for 2017 - on 18 I'm back in Denver
those tickets are on sale I'm in Denver
um and that's it right now I'm all over
though I'm all over so T fat K for Brian
and myself but I'm Clues casino and then
Nashville on the 11th or 10th and 11th
of November Columbus funnybone Ohio on
the 12th and then Ontario improv that is
in inland California not Ontario Canada
there's November 30th and I'm I'm back
Denver I'm finally coming back that's
not the favorite first Tommy works it
down town get joke tickets defect k da
bears and anything else B um that's it
buddy I think I mean you know I'm not
Hobbs
San Francisco until December seventh
eighth or ninth we're going white
truffle we're going white truffle
tonight
white truffle we're going deep you have
to sniff some white truffle correct the
devil's lettuce the devil's dandruff the
devil's dandruff this is a fine kid
we're out